e-commerce is going to undergo a high number of changes because of technological and social factors.
I'll describe the future of e-commerce and nine trends that will exist in the year 2030.
Number one, Augmented Reality will gain mainstream acceptance. Augmented Reality simulates
in-person shopping experiences by allowing customers to see how a product might look on them or in
their home. With AR, customers click on the product and instantly see it overlaid wherever they
point their mobile device. And when customers can view products from every conceivable angle
in an interactive 360 degree experience, it gives them a better idea on the value that the product
can offer. Smart phones, smart glasses, and other handheld and wearable devices will provide
a bulk of these experiences. Shopify AR is an example of a tool that already allows customers
to view products in natural environments before buying them. This helps to ensure that the product
is a good fit for the purpose intended. This helps customers make informed decisions quickly
when it comes to choosing a brand to buy from. And here's what most people don't realize. Augmented
Reality is likely to be more widely used than virtual reality. According to Grandview Research,
the global virtual reality market will be worth 67 billion in 2028. By comparison,
the Augmented Reality global market will be worth 140 billion in 2028. That means that the Augmented
Reality global market will likely be five times larger than the virtual reality global market.
Number two, Jarvis-like AI assistants will begin to become popular. Most people in developed countries
could have AI assistants to improve the quality of their lives. According to Peter Diamondis,
founder of Singular University, services like Alexa, Google Home, and Apple HomePod will expand
in functionality. They will eventually expand beyond just the home and become a cognitive
prosthetic 24-7. Depending on what permissions you grant to it, a secured Jarvis-like software
can listen to all of your conversations, read your emails, monitor your blood chemistry,
and more. With answers to all of this data, this AI-enabled software will learn your preferences
and anticipate your needs and behaviors, shop for you, monitor your health, and help you
problem solve and support your mid and long-term goals. And by the mid-2030s, we will begin using
brain-computer interfaces to connect to the human neural cortex, according to Ray Kurzweil.
This will allow us to interact with AI assistants with their brain activity and bring this technology
to an entirely new level. Number three, crypto may become a common payment option.
To reach more consumers, especially generation Z and millennials, branch would need to accept
as many payment options as possible. The price fluctuations for cryptocurrencies may begin to stabilize
over the next decade, which will make them more attractive payment options for large companies
like Amazon and large payment processing companies like PayPal. On top of that, most cryptocurrencies
use blockchain technology to record transactions. Basically, blockchain is a shared database that
allows multiple parties to access data and verify that data in real time. Blockchain's make it
difficult or impossible to change, hack, or cheat the system. According to Grandview V-shirts,
the global blockchain technology market will grow from 6 billion in 2021 to 395 billion in
2028. That's a whopping 65 times increase in just several years, with such a massive increase in
the use of blockchain technology. Most industries will have a far greater familiarity with blockchain
and cryptocurrencies in general. Number four, autonomous delivery drones could become mainstream.
Delivery drones are capable of handling and automated shipping in different volumes,
all without human intervention. The advantages of automated shipping for e-commerce are many.
They include speed and delivery time, reduction of flight cost, accident reduction, decrease in
human error, reduction of CO2 emissions, and customer satisfaction. Amazon Prime Error will deliver
packages up to 5 pounds within 30 minutes or less using small drones. Amazon has been developing
and testing the platform through Prime Error development centers in the US, the UK, Austria,
France, and Israel. And in August 2020, Amazon received approval from the FAA to operate its Prime
Error delivery drones to safely and efficiently deliver packages to customers. Also, UBS Flight Forward
was the first company to get the US government's full certification to operate a drone airline.
Number five, Virtual Reality will play an essential part of marketing initiatives.
The use of Virtual Reality devices will allow people to view products from any angle imaginable
and see those products in action within virtual environments. With Virtual Reality,
we could quickly change the type of product we are looking at and change the environment so that
we could view the products in different contexts. It's expected to transform multiple industries
such as education, social media, video games, and entertainment. Number six,
in that purchases on social media platforms will be commonplace. Facebook and Instagram
make it easier than ever to let consumers buy products without ever leaving those platforms.
Facebook Shops lets you set up a shop that people can browse and less people buy your products
directly on Facebook. Instagram's separable posts allow you to add your products to your Instagram
post. Likewise, Pinterest has a viable pens feature that allows shoppers to buy products
directly on Pinterest. These are perfect tools for companies to increase their sales,
because 54% of social media users research products using social media.
Notting that, these tools simplify and shorten the customer journey and reduce abandoned transactions.
Number seven, emerging markets will play a huge role. In July 2021,
there were more than 4.8 billion users online that was 63% of the world's population of 7.7 billion.
Cybersecurity Ventures predicts that there would be 7.5 billion internet users by 2030.
That would be 90% of the projected world population of 8.5 billion in 2030.
A high percent of those additional internet users will live in the emerging markets like India,
China, Brazil, Russia, and South Africa. That's going to lead to an extra 2.7 billion potential
consumers on the internet. That could lead to a massive increase in profits for the
commerce-based companies of all sizes. Number eight, voice commerce will grow in popularity.
Voice commerce will top 40 billion in the US by 2022. Even though the global smart speaker
market is growing rapidly, the majority of voice activity occurs on mobile devices through
virtual assistance. It's also very common for consumers to use voice search features
in search engines such as Google and Bing, search for products. Since voice search typically
happens in a form of questions, the page ranking on various websites and web pages could be greatly
affected over time. Number nine, more product descriptions will be in the video format.
According to studies conducted by social media today, 60% of shoppers would rather watch a product
than read a product description. Also, 64% of shoppers are more likely to purchase a product
after watching branded videos on social media. These studies help prove that shoppers will
more interactive experiences when making a purchase to better understand the value being offered.
Additionally, the video format is ideal for providing product demonstrations and utilizing
internet influences. Amazon is already using more product descriptions in the video format,
and this trend will only continue to grow throughout the entire e-commerce space.
Thanks for watching. Make sure to watch the video to the right about the future of augmented reality.